[Musica]
grazie grazie
buongiorno a tutti oggi ho il compito di
parlare di tempo di parlare di tempo in
una logica di sostenibilità e vi parlerò
di sughero vi parlerò di un po cose che
tutti noi conosciamo ma probabilmente
non lo conosciamo sufficientemente per
farvi un paragone su cosa vuol dire il
concetto di sviluppo sostenibile
il sughero esiste né al mondo molto
prima dell uomo pensate che il sughero è
un patrimonio del mediterraneo e che è
una quercia una quercia della famiglia
della rovere che ha sviluppato questa
corteccia per proteggerla dal fuoco
perché in questa zona del mondo milioni
di anni fa c'era il fuoco e il sughero
questa corteccia fatta di aria è
talmente potente che evita che l'albero
bruci perciò un concetto di tempo
diciamo milena re un concetto di tempo
che si interfaccia con la velocità dei
giorni di oggi pensate che il sughero è
un patrimonio da un mediterraneo perché
noi lo troviamo soprattutto nei bacini
occidentali da un mediterraneo lo
troviamo nella penisola iberica tra cui
anche il mio paese che il principale
produttore di sughero perciò lo voglio
contrapporre ai tempi della velocità ai
tempi del tutto è veloce perché se tu
non fai le cose che hai perso l'attimo e
si tu hai perso l'attimo
quell'opportunità non ce l'avrai più
invece c'è un mondo un mondo parallelo
quello che io definisco
slow e mondo slot dove chiaramente la
natura ha i suoi tempi
pensate che questo patrimonio è uno dei
35 santuari di biodiversità nel mondo un
albero di sughero per diventare adulto
ci mette ben 25 anni e ogni nove anni
venne decorticato come viene posata una
pecora un tappo di sughero riesce a
diventare tappo dopo 45 anni perciò sono
250 anni di questo albero che vegeta tra
di noi è un albero estremamente
sostenibile perché aiuta a regolare il
ciclo idrogeologico previene alla
desertificazione sociale e ambientale
impiegando più di 100.000 persone è una
materia rinnovabile e soprattutto non si
buttano giù gli alberi per produrre i
tappi di sughero trattiene anche 112
grammi di co2 è una materia unica che
pensate che in un centimetro cubo di un
tappo di sughero ci sono 800 milioni
dice allora perciò un tappo di sughero
da al vino perché è il principale
elemento per chiudere una bottiglia di
vino dona eleganza prestigio è un valore
classico perciò parliamo di un qualcosa
che ha che vedere teatri e col tempo
perché per noi il tempo è un valore
estremamente importante un valore
estremamente importanti perché essere
sostenibile è un valore estremamente
importante perché la sostenibilità non
va intesa solo come sostenibilità
ambientale alla socialità è un qualcosa
di più ampio d'accordo con la
dichiarazione delle nazioni unite da un
1987 essere sostenibile
bisogna avere la capacità di soddisfare
i propri fabbisogni senza compromettere
i bisogni delle generazioni future
pensate che noi come esseri umani
dobbiamo lasciare ai nostri figli almeno
il mondo che abbiamo ereditato dai
nostri genitori perciò sviluppo
sostenibile non è solo ambiente sviluppo
sostenibile
anche sviluppo economico sostenuta
economiche anche sostenibilità sociale
quello che di cui io vi voglio parlare
oggi perciò qual è la sfida la sfida e
come riuscire a vendere slam nei tempi
da un fast questa è la sfida che io mi
pongo tutti i giorni con tutti i miei
manager con tutti i miei collaboratori
come riuscire a vendere sulla nei tempi
da un fast perciò la cultura diventa
fondamentale perché è quella che
riuscirà a trasmettere i valori e alla
sostenibilità solo attraverso la cultura
la diffusione di questa cultura
io riuscirò a inculcare nella testa
delle persone che hanno che fare con noi
quello che il valore di quello che io
propongo perciò il nostro primo target
kids sono chiaramente vuoi i consumatori
perciò il mio primo obiettivo è quello
di informare i consumatori consumatori
oggi stanno cambiando oggi stanno
cambiando oggi la grande tendenza del
consumo cioè i grandi la grande effetto
il segmento che più interessa a chi
vende sono i millennio i millenials sono
quelle persone che sono diventati adulti
nel passaggio da un millennio perciò io
credo la maggior parte di voi allora
detto questo come ragione il milan
il millennio qual è il tipo di focus che
lui cerca nei momenti in cui lui deve
acquistare qualcosa lui cerca
soprattutto le giuste cause
perciò è fondamentale che ognuno ogni
ogni prodotto in qualche maniera
incorporee questa giusta causa ma da noi
abbiamo deciso di fare comunicazione
proprio di questa giusta causa dei tappi
perciò riuscire a dare a questi tappi
quello che il valore intrinseco da un
punto di vista della sostenibilità in
modo che chi stata una bottiglia capisca
che quello ha un valore il valore è un
valore importante da difendere questo
diventa un aspetto fondamentale per
distinguerci di tutta una serie di altri
prodotti che invece sono di matrice
artificiale e dopo i media io ritengo
saranno dieci anni che noi gestiamo i
rapporti con i media e probabilmente
siamo anche una specie di crystal nella
modo di rapportarsi con i media perché i
media diventano per noi un veicolo
fondamentale perciò parla di televisione
parlo di radio parlo di carta stampata
parlo di blogger parlo di internet
social network tutti i media diventano
fondamentale per diffondere questo
messaggio perciò quando io porto un
giornalista un blogger a toccare con
mano questa materia
loro si innamorano e la morano e in un
modo tale che sentono anche su questo
piacere di difendere una causa giusta e
cominciano a vedere questo prodotto
quando gli occhi completamente diversi
perciò questo dopo si traduce in quello
che è la comunicazione quello che arriva
dopo a ciascuno di voi perché questo il
nostro compito il compito di creare
cultura qual è il risultato il risultato
è chiaramente che un giornalista o un
cliente che ha capito questa cosa
diventa un nostro ambasciatore perciò
una persona che andrà a diffondere
questa cultura e più cultura vuol dire
più valore aggiunto allora tuttavia sono
questo non basta perché questo è l'asse
della sostenibilità ambientale ma come
vi ho detto sostenibilità ambientale non
è solo ambiente accesso senza non è solo
l'ambiente insostenibilità e anche
economia e sociale
quando parliamo di economia
quando parliamo di risultati le aziende
non esistano per caso le aziende
esistono perché ci sono le persone e le
persone diventano fondamentale cioè la
tua squadra è fondamentale perché per
diffondere questo valore aggiunto per
cercare di promuovere questo concerto
perciò il nostro ruolo è quello di
essere manager di talento
cioè il concetto di one man show io vidi
che voi obbedite questo concetto oggi
non funziona più
anzi non credo che sia mai funzionato
quello che oggi funziona è essere in
grado di gestire il talento perché le
persone hanno di alle capacità enorme
bisogna andare a stuzzicare questa
capacità bisogna attraverso quello che
io definisco la re la delega dire in
salita riuscire a fare a capire a queste
persone che adoro
non sono un gatto loro sono un leone
perché tutti noi abbiamo un mero né
dentro di noi
bisogna svegliare questo leone allora
noi siamo le lenze del cambiamento
cioè le cose non cambiano per decreto le
cose cambiano perché noi vogliamo più le
cose cambiano e per questo è imperativo
che il manager abbia la capacità di far
uscire le persone di quella che io
definisco la loro zone di comfort cioè
devono andare fuori di quella zona dove
si addormentano e invece mettersi in
gioco costantemente e allora come si fa
questo cioè come si riesce a mettere in
gioco costantemente una persona come si
riesce allenare un collaboratore
cioè io parto da questo da un potential
of development analysis cioè quello che
il potenziale c'è all'analisi dal
potenziale di sviluppo cioè io vada
vedere attraverso un diagnostico quelli
che sono il potenziale quello come è
costruito il terreno di quella persona
perché alle là di quello che può essere
un intervista un colloquio di lavoro
quello non ti dice niente ti dice
soprattutto quello che come è costruita
questa persona cola il suo profilo psico
attitudinale ed ecco che il risultato si
trasforma in una specie di un istogramma
che ti permette di capire esattamente
come è costruito questo terreno fertile
e questo terreno fertile a tre macro
area l'aria dal sentire l'aria
dell'energia e l'area
relazione dalla correlazione da queste
aree io riesco a individuare come io
posso effettivamente seminare i frutti
giusti perché in questo terreno fertile
possa crescere o quasi di importante sia
per la persona sia anche per la mia
aziende perciò si tratta di capire quali
sono i muscoli a potenziare quali sono i
muscoli invece che sono già
perfettamente potenziate e adatti a
quelle che sono le sfide perché solo
avendo il team giusto si riesce anche a
sfidare quello che sono oggi le regole
del mercato
anche la formazione diventa fondamentale
perché hai individuato le persone sai
chi sono quelle persone che ti servono
ma adesso devi formarli e soprattutto
non solo i collaboratori che tu hai in
azienda ma soprattutto quelle che sono
sul mercato quelle che devono passare
quello che il tuo valore allora quello
che noi cerchiamo di fare e io cerco di
fare è far sviluppare il concetto di
essere imprenditori di te stesso perché
perché uno quando si sveglia alla
mattina deve sapere cosa deve fare deve
sapere dove deve andare deve sapere qual
è il valore che lui deve passare al
mercato allora io utilizzo da qualche
tempo questo moderno business model
canvas un modo molto semplice di
insegnare come fare un business plan
come cercare in qualche maniera di
definire qual è il mio tragitto ma non
il mio tragitto da questa settimana
bisogna guardare questa almeno con uno
spazio temporale di tre anni perché sono
e nei tre anni che io riesco chiaramente
a cambiare qualcosa perché ogni giorno
noi cambiamo ma cambiamo solo un
pezzettino l'altro aspetto fondamentale
è quello di sviluppare il senso di
appartenenza delle persone perciò la
motivazione alla motivazione di far
parte dal gruppo la motivazione di
vestire la maglietta dell'azienda e
questo diventa fondamentale perchè così
tu avrai dei guerrieri che combatteranno
insieme a te e così tu avrai capito che
solo insieme si vince
e questo diventa
questa componente che io definisco di
sostenibilità economica che permette
effettivamente a tutti i tuoi
collaboratori di essere allineati con
quello che è il tuo progetto e per
ultimo la componente della sostenibilità
sociale
io sono convinto che essere sostenibile
vuol dire anche essere capace di
spendersi per gli altri cercare in
qualche maniera di aiutare il
circondario aiutare il territorio dove
tu sei inserito noi lo facciamo da anni
perché un'azienda si nutrì da un
territorio e questo territorio
ti da i dipendenti ti da i fornitori ma
tu devi anche dare al di là di questo
alle la di pagare stipendi al di là di
pagare le fatture devi lasciare qualcosa
in questo territorio perché
effettivamente questo territorio merita
che tu lo aiuti allora nel 2011
ho creato quello che è il volto sociale
della mia azienda si chiama progetto
etico guidi cos'è questo progetto etico
cos'è questa cosa abbiamo deciso di
raccogliere i tappi usati ognuno di voi
sicuramente beve da un vino dopo siamo
in veneto per ciò a maggior ragione
beh vedo vino quando stappati alla
bottiglia guardate questo tappo non
sapete dove metterlo allora abbiamo
detto ma perché questo tappo noi non lo
recuperiamo e andiamo a macinare questo
tappo trasformandolo in un materiale di
coibentazione perché sapete che il
sughero è il più grande isolante
naturale che esiste sulla terra perché
ricordatevi che protegge l'albero dal
fuoco
allora abbiamo iniziato questo progetto
abbiamo raccolto più di 350 milioni di
tappi in dal 2011 ad oggi in sei anni
non sono tanti considerato che oggi
vengono buttati nella spazzatura circa
800 milioni di tappi all'anno
noi siamo riusciti a intercettare una
piccola parte e vi dico che abbiamo
generato un movimento grandioso perché
tutte le persone si domandavano
questi tappi perché non si possono
recuperare allora abbiamo oggi più di
5000 punti di raccolta nel centro e nord
italia e anche in poche parti dal sud
italia
abbiamo più di mille volontari che
lavorano con noi e che ci aiutano a
recuperare i tanti noi recuperiamo i
tappi li trasportiamo con dei mezzi
autorizzati
immaginiamo e dopo li rivendiamo ad
aziende di bioedilizia e qual è il
risultato cioè il risultato che noi
siamo riusciti ad ottenere prima di
tutto siamo riusciti a donare più di
200mila euro in beneficenza e questo è
già un traguardo importante perché
andiamo ad aiutare tantissime delle 40
onlus che lavorano con noi ma
soprattutto siamo riusciti a chiudere il
cerchio un cerchio iniziato nella
foresta con un movimento estremamente
sostenibile rispettoso dell'ambiente
passando per il modo come noi
approcciamo il mercato fino a quello che
il fine vita dei nostri prodotti
allora cosa farei io con un'ora in più
cosa fare io con un ora in più al giorno
o 40 minuti tanto non è rilevante
io cercherò di rendere il mio passaggio
per il pianeta terra
il più sostenibile possibile e
probabilmente facendo così io non avrò
bisogno di andare a cercare acqua su
marte
grazie
[Applauso]